I'm here to see mr. black it's for the
paper
- what do you owe your success I have a
natural instinct for what makes a person
tick
Hannah Christian oh look hurts whoa
please God why girls get that a little
bit of face give me a smile okay no
smile don't ever smile again so how did
you make your money I exercise control
in all things miss Steele and you don't
want somebody like me
daleon
I'll do romance I need to know why you
won't have a real relationship with me
let's just say my life wasn't always
easy
my stepdad Ron is a little
overprotective are you thinking about
Marin Oh what does she get pregnant
still no but hell nah I like this
I'm just the dominant show me the worst
service wall do you break my stool No
you have to talk you mean like why
people what's wrong with that and they
start throwing around all these big SAT
words I like it's a black way what's
your not going to don't know won't you
not college it I'm not about it don't
let me get the clapping boom I'll hang
up see that's communication
let up as a whole it wasn't even Spring
Break huh hey he later he had habits of
them ethnicity oops
just the citizens need hte Positas a
Mista